here with reaction media reporter for
the hill and radio talk show host on wor
my affiliate grade station in New York
City Joe Concha and of course journalist
former 60 minutes correspondent Lauren
Logan is with us thank you both
Lara we'll begin with you you know look
at that reaction is interesting I think
people get it I think Democrats don't
get it we'll see more overreach more
more investigations and of course more
socialism which would destroy the
country your reaction to all this well
you know my first reaction shown is that
as a journalist I mean speculation is
not what I do right I prefer to focus on
what I do know and I'm always very
conscious of what I don't know and I
want to give you like just a simple
example in some of the coverage that I
think demonstrates where the media is
culpable for example do you remember
what all the headlines in the media
frenzy around president Trump supposedly
leaking classified information to the
Russians at a meeting in the White House
right except that no reporter actually
seen appeared to look at what the law
says about classified information and
the President of the United States not
just this president but every single
president the commander in chief and a
US law is the only single individual
who's active speaking about something is
an act of declassification so you talk
to anyone in the intelligence community
who knows the law or anyone at all who
knows the laws on classified information
they will tell you it's not possible for
the president to leak but that was used
by the media and right across the
spectrum every reputable newspaper and
outlet in this country was you know hot
and heavy on the president leaking
classified information with the Russians
as further evidence that he was somehow
some kind of traitor and and Russian
agents and to me the most basic
journalism it only takes a couple
minutes to look online and see what the
law actually says about this and do some
honest reporting and I think for that
it's a dereliction of our duty as
reporters all right Joe country do you
do this for a living you analyze this
do they ever recover this has been two
years of never and
non-stop lies and conspiracy theories it
frankly they ought to be apologizing and
embarrassed that'll never happen
Shawn I think we got a snapshot just
based on ratings aren't everything
clearly but last night Monday night the
the fact that you more than quadrupled
your competition on CNN Tucker Carlson
as well and right down the line and the
fact that you're getting more than four
million viewers and CNN could even break
915,000 I think maybe that that maybe a
preview of things to come that they've
been promising not all but many people
on those networks whether it be CNN or
MSNBC have been promising a certain
outcome or at least strongly hinting
towards it speculating about it which
does nothing for the eyes and minds by
the way for to basically hey what's the
worst thing in life you can do
over-promised and under-delivered
they have been shown to their audiences
it's imminent imminent today's time
right and it was time to cash the check
and the check was in cash and now
there's disappointment that's why maybe
some people were more people than usual
we're tuning out last night but let's
think about this for a second in terms
of Muller in terms of that investigation
the special counsel they hardly by all
accounts leaked anything so think about
it the pushback I saw today was well we
had to pursue the investigation we had
to pursue the facts but around collusion
if the special counsel isn't leaking
therefore this only leads to rampant
reckless speculation by people from
sources that were providing information
to them that was either bad or nefarious
and they wanted to believe what they
were being fed because if there were no
facts out there around collusion because
of no leaking that's the only thing that
could have happened
bad speculation that led to all this
mistrust that we're gonna be seeing
moving forward they can't recover from
my perspective we'll see Laura Thank You
Jose Concha thank you